fermera fermera pas aujourd'hui l'école
est au centre de tous les débats la
gestion de la crise sanitaire dans les
écoles aux multiples changements de
protocole le protocole sanitaire qui ne
cesse de changer avec l'explosion des
cas qu vider les protocoles sanitaires
quasi impossible à respecter les
professeurs sont arrivés à saturation il
ya un ras-le bol qui s'exprime par
rapport à un autre ministre depuis la
rentrée normale quatre protocoles
différents il faut dire que pratiquer
des tests pcr sur des enfants de 6 ans
pas facile
le premier ministre et ex a donc
préconisé les autotests plus sympa
réaliser et pour désengorger les
pharmacies trois autos tech plutôt qu'un
pc air express annonce qui n'ont pas
suffi à faire décoller les
professionnels de l'éducation qui
appelle une grève générale ce jeudi
du 3 janvier c'est la goutte d'eau qui
fait déborder le vase c'est le
déclencheur mais la colère elle est là
depuis bien plus longtemps que la moitié
des établissements scolaires devrait
donc fermer dès ce soir une mobilisation
historique
alors face au ras-le-bol faut-il fermer
définitivement les écoles
merci et notre secrétaire d'état malin
et miss je peux vous dire madame la
ministre wallon du secrétaire d'état
parce que je sais jamais en fait madame
on dire merci à toi on a rebondi à l'est
on arrondit sarra el aissi d'être avec
nous qui est chargé de la jeunesse merci
d'être là et merci à benjamin amar merci
benjamin prof d'histoire et porte parole
de la cgt du val de marne la question
que j'ai envie de poser à tout le monde
peut-il fermer les écoles c'est la
question qu'on se pose demain et les
normes grève il ya plein valade de 2,2
d'étudiants enfin là deux jours qui sont
à l'école qui déconnait qui seront pas
l'école demain faut-il fermer
définitivement les écoles benjamin
qu'est ce t'en penses toi alors il est
évident que parmi les pays européens il
ya des pays qui ont allongé la période
des vacances ce qui in fine et signifie
effectivement fermé les écoles
provisoirement moi j'ai envie de dire
depuis deux ans l'école elle est dans
une situation catastrophique calamiteuse
c'est à dire que on a payé très cher
pédagogiquement le coc vide donc
vraiment ce serait la solution là je
dirais l'ultime solution celle que il
faut éviter à tout prix mais pour ça
faut mettre les moyens il faut mettre
les moyens cyril vous savez quoi la
journée aujourd'hui j'étais à l'école
moi dans la vie réelle je suis prof
espérons que j'étais au lycée prat
histoire qu'est ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui puisque mon lycée est en
droit de retrait depuis lundi c'est j'ai
corrigé mes copies en salle des profs
avec ou mentaux mais gand et mon bonnet
parce qu'en réalité las la solution
qu'on a dans les établissements depuis
deux ans ces deux d'ouvrir nos fenêtres
voilà la réalité c'est celle là donc on
peut les pelles en salle des profs on se
les pelles saporta d'avoir vraiment ce
qui se passerait si
la réalité c'est ça un âne ou des
revendications matérielles précises pour
pouvoir justement essayer de maintenir
une activité pédagogique avec des moyens
supplémentaires emmanuel macron il a dit
on est en guerre alors qu'on fait pas la
guerre avec des jouets en plastique il
faut des moyens sonnants et trébuchants
et là dessus on ne peut effectivement
que compter sur finalement la
communication de jean michel blanquer
communication bien souvent au kérosène
qui a qu'à écouter encore les derniers
propos qu'il a tenus alors qui sait que
la grève de jeudi elle va être massive
il nous dit on fait pas la grève contre
un virus nommé merci on n'est pas débile
c'est jean-michel pierrafeu ce type par
le feu aux poudres et donc on a cette
communication au kérosène et les moyens
sonnants et trébuchants pour
effectivement faire face aux
combinaisons ne les a pas alors merci à
saray diaries est vrai qu est-ce qu on
avoir des réponses secrétaire d'état
chargée de la jeunesse et de
l'engagement quand vous entendez
benjamins à maintenir c'est à dire on
est obligé d'ouvrir les fenêtres parce
qu'on n'a pas d'autre moyen parce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est que pour
répondre à cette crise effectivement la
facilité aurait pu aurait aurait pu être
de fermer les écoles fermer les classes
et dire bon ben on est désolé mais c'est
le plus simple ce qu'on a fait c'est un
choix totalement différent la seule et
unique boussole qui a été la nôtre c'est
de dire la priorité ce sont les enfants
et pour ça et bien il faut un maximum de
moyens à l'école pour accompagner les
enseignants pour accompagner les parents
pour accompagner les directeurs d'école
et si l'école elle a tenu pendant autant
de temps pendant deux ans à la tenue est
ouverte c'est parce qu'en fait tout le
temps tout le monde sait adapter les
enseignants les parents rappelez-vous le
premier confinement quand les parents
ont fait et classe à la maison avec la
veille avec des équipes pédagogiques
vous avez tout le monde était confiné et
là et là je vais arriver au moyen pour
les parents c'est un service qui vivent
hors de france mais je vais juste arrivé
aux moyens les moyens c'est quoi parler
de moyens cha mars et cette année c'est
53 milliards d'euros l'école c'est une
augmentation de 1 milliard d'euros après
je vais vous dire ce que les moyens très
concrets qui ont été mis en place mais
vraiment pour la crise qu vite parce que
les transformations elles ont continué
mais pour la crise covic c'est toi c'est
170 millions de masques qui ont été
distribués immédiatement c'est
évidemment des protocoles qui ont bougé
et c'est normal c'est dur et c'est pas
simple et franchement le premier qui dit
tu as quelque chose à quelle personne
n'était préparé et premier qui disent et
c'est simple de trouver il ya une seule
réponse c'est pas vrai moi ce que j'ai
envie de faire ce que j'ai envie de
partager avec vous aujourd'hui c'est en
réalité 50 priorité pour l'école louis
deux ans de qu'ovide où on n'a pas pu
parler de ce que font les enseignants
pour améliorer le niveau de lecture et
d'écriture des enfants ce qu'on a fait
pour les accompagner sur les devoirs
faits parce que fermer l'école c'est
finalement pénaliser ceux qui ont le
moins de moyens c'est le pénaliser les
enfants dont les parents ne peuvent pas
les aider c'est ceux qui n'ont pas
d'ordinateur à la maison ils n'ont pas
de chambre ou pas finalement pas tout le
soutien familial
et donc ça c'était notre priorité alors
oui c'est vrai c'est pas simple et c'est
passé simple pour personne parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'on a pris une décision on
l'a prise en s'appuyant sur les médecins
les autorités sanitaires les
informations qu'on avait donc deux ans
que c'est bien l'école les écoles vont
pas fermer très sincèrement ses lacets
abandonné qui sont formés les écoles
break c'est la dernière chose c'est ce
qu'avait dit c'est ça le projet la
république mais comme jean michel
blanquer comme franchement tout l'est en
réalité un peu tout le corps etc c'est
vraiment lamentable alors vraiment il
parle d'un principe c'est vraiment
jamais fermé mais ça serait abandonné
les enfants et on ne fait pas de manière
dogmatique l'école c'est quoi en vrai
c'est l'endroit où est ben y en a qui
prennent des petits déjeuners il y en a
qui mange le midi grâce à la cantine
c'est des enseignants qui accueille la
parole des enfants quand il y à des
violences ce soit les enfants les
adolescents regardez tous les médecins
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit l'état
psychologique des enfants qui se dégrade
dans les pays qui ont fermé l'allemagne
elle a fermé deux fois plus que nous
l'italie trois fois plus les états unis
quatre fois plus je sais que c'est pas
simple et en fait c'est simple pour
personne en vrai c'est complet pas
d'accord explique ce 14 mai moyen âge
les moyens ils sont là et je ne vais
peut-être qu'un à part évidemment encore
elle a réveillé mais fatigué au
quotidien vous les sentez pas les moyens
vous mais non c'est pas vrai non mais
non mais enfin on ne tenait pas à notre
premier débat à la mairie on débattait
quand vous étiez encore débuté et je
pense qu'à un moment il faut arrêter je
faut arrêter de 2,2 vers le moulin à
vent je viens de vous dire que le débat
c'est pas la fermeture des écoles qu'on
souhaite éviter ça par contre et à la
question des moyens matériels vous dites
on peut pas laisser les enfants les
abandonner c'est quoi j'ai 60 %
d'absents parmi mes élèves en ce moment
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une continuité
pédagogique quand on a 40% de ses élèves
dans mon établissement
on établissements ya 130 cas positif
j'ai 12 % de des élèves du lycée qui
sont cas positif jeudi il va y avoir le
syndicat national des chefs
d'établissements le syndicat de chefs
d'établissement qui sont en grève avec
nous ça fait 25 ans que je suis prof
j'ai jamais vu ça on est à un niveau de
gravité madame quand je vous entends
parler des masques excusez moi mais je
joue mieux entendre ça que d'être sourd
nuestro nous a distribué une marche de
vous dire dans la vie réelle c'est parce
que visiblement il ya une faille spatio
temporelle entre ce qui se passe rue de
grenelle et dans les établissements moi
j'ai reçu au rythme des cinq mâts sophie
nissan à vannes en tissu à la rentrée
2020 ils ont été retirés cette brève ce
que je vous dis l'algérie ils ont été
retirés de la circulation parce que
visiblement ça n'est pas trop les
utiliser il était peut-être pas super
bon pour la santé basta le reste
naccache ou alou par contre
il a des revendications lorsqu'on à 12 %
des élèves dans mon établissement qui
sont cas positifs j'ai envie de vous
dire dans quelle entreprise on a 12 %
des effectifs qui sont cas positifs et
ont dit aux salariés et c'est quoi vous
ouvrez les fenêtres pendant deux ans
je courais marrakech du rire l'autre
[Applaudissements]
les purificateurs d'air de co2 les
moyens supplémentaires c'est ce qu'on
dit nous c'est un peu ses intérêts on
réfléchit à la cgt odimo bahigwa vu que
on a un problème de brassage d'air
pourquoi on réquisitionne pas des
bâtiments comme ça on aura peu d'élèves
dans beaucoup de bas dans un temps plus
l'espace et donc on pourra continuer à
faire court parce que notre obsession
c'est bien de maintenir l'école ouverte
mais pas dans les conditions déplorables
dans laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui et
vous vous continuez nous dire ce qu'on
fait c'est formidable c'est vrai que
c'est dur mais on va continuer comme ça
non on va pas continuer comme ça et
c'est pour ça que demain vous allez
avoir une main